concilier ces deux dimensions haut et
énergie dans des contextes temporels et
spatiaux aussi différents n'est pas
chose aisée et ça il faut le qu'on
l'intègre tous collectivement nous avons
depuis des années adapté notre gestion
pour y faire face nous relâchons des
centaines de millions de mètres cubes
chaque année pour d'autres usages tout
en assurant les besoins de flexibilité
du système électrique puisque c'est la
qualité première de l'hydroélectricité
la mobilisation des réservoirs
hydrauliques est déjà largement activée
comme je vous le disais deux tiers des
concessions hydrauliques ont déjà
d'autres usages de l'eau que la
production d'énergie dans beaucoup
d'endroits le fait que les barrages
hydroélectriques servent d'autres usages
ainsi masquer le besoin d'adaptation au
changement climatique des bénéficiaires
nous avons tenu en 2022 dans un contexte
doublement inédit une sécheresse
exceptionnelle l'été qui nous a conduit
à déstocker bien plus que la normale 800
millions de mètres cubes
soit en 2022 donc soit 60% de plus que
la moyenne 2015 2021
et plusieurs retenus ont été totalement
vidés à la limite de la vidange
et en même temps gérer un risque sur la
provisionnement en énergie pour l'hiver
puisqu'on a on s'attendait un hiver très
tendu ce qui sera encore le cas cette
année 2023 puisqu'on s'attend un été
déjà tendu du point de vue de l'eau et
puis on s'attend à un hiver compliqué
encore sur l'équilibre offre de demande
sur le réseau et donc ce qui nous a
conduit à devoir constituer en même
temps que cette gestion utilisage de
l'eau des réserves d'eau suffisantes
pour passer l'hiver et les pointes de
consommation
dernièrement il y a aussi des limites
même purement physique à l'exercice et
des leurs éventuels mobilisations
supplémentaires des retenus et
hydroélectriques ne seront pas une
solution miracle d'une part parce que
nos installations ne sont pas
géographiquement toujours localisées là
où se trouvent les besoins en eau je
crois que le directeur de l'eau et la
biodiversité monsieur Thibault l'a
exprimé aussi devant vous lors de son
audition d'autre part parce que les
volumes seraient insuffisants en fait
pour couvrir l'ensemble des besoins ceci
étant rendu croissant par les besoins
liés au changement climatique
notre conviction profonde et qu'il n'est
pas question de sacrifier une des
dimensions au énergie au bénéfice de
l'autre notre défi collectif est bien de
réussir de front et la transition
énergétique et la gestion durable de la
ressource en eau pour nous il est donc
nécessaire et j'en terminerai par là
au-delà de la contribution des
réservoirs hydro en régime normal qui
continuera de trouver de nouvelles
solutions face aux besoins d'eau soit
par la sobriété des usages soit par la
constitution de nouvelles capacités de
stockage
de continuer à développer
l'hydroélectricité pour les besoins du
système électrique notamment parce qu'on
aura de plus en plus besoin de
flexibilité nous considérons qu'il y a
encore du potentiel de développement en
France et en outre-mer que ce soit dans
un cadre purement énergétique ou
multi-usages de l'eau monsieur le préfet
n'a parlé équilibré comme nos précédés